in five four three two one
hola Nihao
konbanwa I know how say Oh [ __ ]
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain podcast I'm your host David so
ciao I'm your other host Joe just to
college oh I forgot what the ciao
[ __ ] now mr. Chau [ __ ]
hey Joe is back from his [ __ ]
expedition Eurotrip baby guten tag Mara
asses was that your uh for son of Europe
no we went to France together bro [ __ ] I
forgot
shadows to a casing TIFF you're wet it
was lovely I think it's one of those
things where we forgot that it was
actually your it felt like America it
felt like a JK company trip just to
another part of the United States yeah
yeah cuz Paris is just a different place
like I don't know you know what the
hardest part about being in Paris was
was when we were there we I didn't
realize that there are certain parts of
this world obviously because I'm a
[ __ ] stupid American that there's
people who don't use [ __ ] Yelp and
France is one of those places that they
don't give a [ __ ] about Yelp so what
maybe I heard they use other things out
there like Trip Advisor or whatever but
we were out there we were trying to find
good spots to eat and got [ __ ] man like
I went we went to like all these Yelp
spots but they're not French people
using the Yelp spots of course because
it's all in English yeah it's American
tourists who go to these American
tourist traps and they rate them based
on their [ __ ] ass palate yeah and so we
I think like 80% of the places that I
went to in France was terrible not to
knock on France but or Paris but it was
just because we went to every crappy
spot because every I didn't like French
food it was not what we first have but
the bread was good well I mean the bread
was [ __ ] fire everywhere the baked
goods and friends are all amazing I
think the the part where I [ __ ] up
which I didn't know until we found out
after apparently a waffle which I think
it's chicken is their [ __ ] and I was
eating other stuff besides [ __ ]
chicken but I it was their [ __ ] huh yeah
I heard like chicken is like the thing
that they do really really dark is good
too
you know we just had a steak there and I
was like what is this a karai Blair is
not a stick I had their stick that doll
which was very good via the raw cubed up
steak yeah that was great
but yeah France was just one of those
spots that when we went to was it was it
was a good culture break though because
I think that's where they have a lot of
history there yeah and they respect that
a lot and so the history and the
buildings are it's just everywhere but
it was so dirty France is so dirty man
it's a lot of people it's a lot but it
was the dirtiest just from ok I've been
I went to London I went to Prague which
is in the Czech Republic and I went to
Vienna which is in Austria and then
after after visiting all that I was like
Paris is [ __ ] filthy dude really yeah
it's pretty dirty
it's that clean everywhere else maybe
not London but everywhere else yeah
London's is like it's like here it's a
mean but it's just speak a little
differently yeah so like okay so the
here's the game plan right so the game
plan was I'm gonna go with a [ __ ]
one-way ticket to London cousinís cuz
it's it's like London has a lot of
airports so you could get some cheap-ass
tickets mhm
like I even found one ticket it's a
one-way ticket from LAX to London for
150 bucks Norwegian Airlines damn yeah
150 bucks man isn't that crazy
I can't believe you did a one-way ticket
I get scared for doing that [ __ ] I need
to make sure I have an exit plan oh I
did I am for sure I knew that I was
gonna come back from Amsterdam yeah cuz
I was meeting my buddy Kyle out there
hmm
so I said okay for sure I'm gonna go to
London cuz I always wanted to go to the
UK I wanted to check out like we just
have a huge fan base there and my friend
was meeting out there meeting me out
there anyway so I was like whatever and
I knew I was gonna fly back from the
Netherlands in between though for the
next three weeks we didn't know what we
were gonna do so that's when I was like
alright let's do it man because if I
didn't have JK news to come back to I
wouldn't have gotten a ticket
back home oh you were to say that longer
no I mean I would have just got a ticket
there and flew back from whatever city
was convenient you know so yeah I mean
it all just kind of worked out that way
but originally here's the plan it was to
go there one-way ticket and just figure
it out that's [ __ ] crazy I can't do
that I get nervous just thinking about
that [ __ ] dude somebody might kidnap me
my big ass
let's [ __ ] scary Matt I ended up at a
dude's house that I've met for two days
I can't do that you're you you live life
on the [ __ ] edge man but I also read
people good Joe who you think you read
well or not receive it I'm [ __ ]
strangers house man well I don't know I
feel like maybe people out in Europe or
maybe different than us cuz I know for
us I think in the United States that's
just not happening man I mean yeah I
mean there's good people everywhere and
there are a lot of so okay I feel safe
to B's is because Davey they've either
watched my stuff in the past so like
they kind of know who I am or they're a
friend of a friend amen I invited
somebody to this podcast that was
actually something and I almost got
[ __ ] distorted so there's a we'll get
to that story later but but at the end
of the day don't you feel like you could
kill somebody before they could kill you
depending did if it's the bedroom it's a
guy or a girl has a guy for sure if it's
a girl and I think they had the upper
they just make up stories on [ __ ] maybe
that's maybe I'm just weird cuz I feel
like you bring me into your house I'm
more dangerous than you guys yeah baby
oh yeah I guess it's the other way
around right that's how I feel yeah yeah
like well if anything happens oh well
what was the first thing you did when
you when you okay so when I went there I
was like well obviously we had to just
[ __ ] we weren't there on a Friday so
it was like well let's check out those
[ __ ] club scene yeah and then you
know I met a couple of people out there
shoutouts to men he owns uh I forgot the
name of the club but he owns a club and
he took care of us
things like [ __ ] Joe come on I'm sorry
man
yeah and I met a couple of guys out
there
really cool dudes yeah and then we just
bonded like he's like you know when you
click with people immediately right and
then the thing is I think also why I
trusted them too is that I met their
family immediately okay so like there
was this but you know that picture I
have of me at a Vietnamese event yeah
when I was looking at that [ __ ] dude I'm
like why did you go to London to go to
the sgv dude what the [ __ ] did you
what's going on here no no so okay I
think it was the day before Christmas
Eve right the night before so one of the
guys dads through the event so he was
just like oh I got to work the event but
there's free food whatever you guys want
to come down and I'm like well [ __ ] I
don't have anything planned so I went
there and we're just eating and hanging
out and I'm meeting people and I'm
listening to traditional Vietnamese
music [ __ ] Paris by night yeah and and
with the two of those while I was in
Europe - what the [ __ ] dude
Vietnamese people have been giving me so
much love like the community is strong
bro like there's what I noticed is that
we were doing JK write all the skits all
this stuff
Asian english-speaking Asians all over
the world that was their childhood mmm
and obviously the Vietnamese like dis
Bora like like the the you know the
former like you know like the like the
expats like the Vietnamese Americans
Vietnamese you know British or whatever
they all connect to the content that we
created mmm and it just so happens that
it all started because my buddy Kyle in
Vietnam he creates content you know
connecting Vietnamese families that were
lost after the war they they whatever
and so he knows like other Vietnamese
kids Vietnamese British or whatever and
they introduced he introduces me to them
and he and you know they it just goes
down the line like that so it just so
happened that
you know they're welcoming in their
communities with open arms and [ __ ] yeah
so I don't know how I got there but I
just got there what in the [ __ ] man
that's such a weird thing to do
so you and they so you you went out
there you landed you went out to a club
and in the next day we're just partying
we're hanging out going on dates
by the way picking up girls out there
and hanging out is super easy everybody
says that
why is that cuz everyone's friendly like
and you just hang out and you you know
you enjoy life like it's not it's I
don't know it's not like LA maybe LA is
a different beast for sure I mean even
from Sacramento to LA yeah la girls I
don't know what it is and it's probably
LA guys too
maybe LA guys are extremely thirsty and
maybe that's why LA girls get really
jaded yeah but there's something about
the city where it was it's it's a lot
more work and effort to even get a just
a comfortable conversation going
depending on where it's going to lead
right I mean obviously there's a lot of
factors depending on where you're going
you know like if it's a highfalutin
area then you're not dressed the part
then obviously people don't ignore you
but yeah something about LA like it's
it's it's not as it can happen but it's
not as easy yeah and I mean I've been
here all my life to write and it's very
cliquish
yeah like you got to know someone that
knows someone or people only stick to
the groups that they come with yeah and
then it's like [ __ ] you to everybody
else but it's kind of an odd thing for
me it's like you know if you're gonna go
on this public space expect for people
to hit on you or you know try say what's
up yeah but it's not like that in like
Europe like well like we'll go have some
shisha or hookah you know and we're just
talking and there'll be a party full of
girls right there and it's like oh hey
where you from and then we'll combine
parties and my friends will pick up get
their numbers [ __ ] go date them after
whatever they're like yeah that's normal
but for them they say that the u.s. they
get laid quicker now they're it's easy
to have conversations and hang out mmm
and then it'll lead to something maybe
am i but they said that their chances
for one-night stands
and the states are quicker and I'm like
where did you go and they're like Vegas
well duh yeah that's that everybody's
there for a one-night stand bro duh yeah
it's Vegas but also they have British
accents so easy one of them tony is a
six-foot vietnamese boy handsome boy the
other guy chip
he's like 511 he's still tall damn I've
never met a six-foot Vietnamese person
there that I an immense tall - I told
him you guys are the tallest [ __ ]
Vietnamese I've ever met yeah they're
usually they're all over 510 that's
crazy you see me in a photo with them
I'm just like man what the [ __ ] dude
yeah I'm like a Japanese [ __ ] that's
cool so you met these dudes I mean you
would Club man what's the last time you
went clubbing dude I can't even remember
and even if I go it's like for work you
know like I'm going to network I'm doing
I never went just to like sip on a drink
and talk to people I actually enjoy
lounges better
yeah lounges are dope lounges have just
get a few drinks and talk and hang out
yeah there's a dope DJ yeah and you know
there's like sometimes these lodges have
a dance floor if you guys want to
[ __ ] you know bumper grinding over
there we went to a rooftop lounge and it
wasn't it wasn't there wasn't music it
was more like a bar yeah it was like
couches really cozy and we just hung out
that was really fun yeah that's dope I
mean lounge is kind of cool I feel like
lounging is the is that always the next
step after clubbing right because you
still want to dress up you still want to
look good you still want to hear dope
music from a dope DJ get drinks but you
just don't like the part where it's
[ __ ] hot and sweating you're bumping
grinding you know I mean yeah so like
lounges for me was like the [ __ ] after a
while we're in the bars and like you
want hit up a bar you want to go to a
lounge
you know this podcast is brought to you
by purple by friends purple mattress has
saved my back has saved my life and US
has saved my sleep time you spend a lot
of your life sleeping on the regular I
don't think you realize how much of our
life is you sleeping and if you're not
having a good night's sleep you don't
know what's going on my friends a purple
mattress just hugs you like a
grandmother's hug it just fills up your
soul makes me feel great
and if
fact ever since I started using purple I
started pop locking again that's a lie
but I love my purple mattress and it
does help out with my sleep because I
slept on a crappy spring mattress before
and it ruined my back so purple thank
you for that check it out you're going
to love purple and right now my
listeners will get a free purple pillow
with the purchase of a mattress that's
in addition to the great free gifts that
are offering site-wide just takes brain
to 84-88 eight the only way to get this
red pillow is a text brain to eight four
- eight eight eight that's be are a in2
eight four eight eight eight
i drink a lot - for some reason i was
able to drink yeah just like I have to
find my safe drinks we're safe dears gin
and tonic since I was a good though like
it doesn't [ __ ] me up oh really
I think I'm [ __ ] up with the wheat or
something might be you might have a go
wheat allergy or some barley or some
[ __ ] like that cuz I got a non-alcoholic
beer we went to like this festival
called winter wonderland and then I just
yeah I drink a non-alcoholic beer and it
still gave me a headache
so I'm like I think it's the wheat man
maybe it's something that and the
alcohol cuz if you're fine with like gin
and tonic then you're okay yeah so I'm
starting out III I can drink I can hang
out and I'm just like oh this is [ __ ]
fun dude it's really fun so I didn't
know what the hell to do because during
London everything closes on Christmas I
get so I was like oh [ __ ] things
actually closed here mmm
like I mean cuz you know it is a
Christmas is a big deal its I was like
that's a white people holiday that's my
[ __ ] yeah
in in LA like you still got a [ __ ] ton
of Asian restaurants a [ __ ] ton all
kinds of other [ __ ] that's open no one
really celebrates Christmas the way they
do it out there yeah out there like they
have these things called Christmas
markets that shit's dope dude oh really
it's like it's like that six to six
night market but like Christmas themed
and it's everywhere like you go to like
a town square you go to like a like one
of those like like those monuments and
[ __ ] and it's just it's just there and
then they have like pretzels and beer
and all
kinds of [ __ ] loca and you have you have
you heard muled wine no what's that
that's [ __ ] delicious dude so they
warm this wine up and then they mix it
with berries and cinnamon and [ __ ] like
that yeah yeah yeah yes so they had it
but I saw it on like a European cooking
show it is so good because well I was
able to drink that - because you can't
taste the alcohol and you know it
doesn't like it creeps on you cuz
there's a high alcohol content but you
can't taste it mmm
so you before I know you're [ __ ] up
but it's like your drink drinking some
good ass juice as you say it's delicious
it was so good man damn so you said you
want a couple dates
yeah you did mother [ __ ] back in the
game baby
that's tight dude that bounce-back game
is dope then you got a rebound like no
[ __ ] other homey
dad and then there really sweet nice
awesome
what's the feel like dating again
amazing like oh dude okay so here's the
thing what I realized is I I thought to
myself in the past like oh I don't want
to go through that again like I don't
want to go through the surge I don't
want to go through like getting to know
somebody all over yeah getting to you
know like what do you call it like like
trying to get approval like trying to
pick up a what I realize is I don't have
to do any of that [ __ ] it's not that
hard yeah especially in Europe it's like
a friend of a friend Oh so-and-so know
so-and-so is like oh this guy's someone
you know he's kind of someone important
or whatever they want to get to know me
or like sliding in the DMS panda ever
since the breakup was official dude the
floodgates have been open now few
[ __ ] loose ass women didn't you're
like now his heart is broken I could
heal it with this [ __ ] you know what
though that was one of the things that
what that was a pick-up line from women
really it was like not not exactly but
not what you said okay [ __ ] this and
feel better yeah but it was it was
straight up like if you need someone to
talk to you know yeah yeah that kind of
[ __ ] and at first my
low self-esteem ass would just really
talk to them and be like yeah so this is
what you know thank you for your time
and then it's like oh wait thank you for
your time
oh wait they actually want it bored yeah
okay well are we are we gonna [ __ ] her
or not it's like well I thought you said
you're just gonna listen to me ready
like yeah no I mean it was crazy like
just I realized that being in a toxic
relationship and it wasn't just toxic
for me it was toxic for Jess to the the
thing was we we really [ __ ] each
other's self-esteem in the past couple
of years like we really made each other
feel small and I think if I can go back
and do it over again I wish I never
[ __ ] her [ __ ] self-esteem up like
that because I realize now how bad that
was cuz I was unaware like it's like
smoking a cigarette like every single
day you smoked one and then before you
know it you got [ __ ] emphysema or
some [ __ ] right yeah it's a slow killer
so over the years you're chipping away
at each other's self worth confidence
whatever it is and you're unaware that
you've been all [ __ ] up yeah so one of
the things that was like you know like
basically I was told I suck at kissing
right and then I mean it was said on JK
news before it's not like a secret or
whatever but I was told that so even
though it might be true to her in my
head I thought that was true to
everybody yeah that was it I was like I
suck at kissing I'm not I'm unromantic
whatever I can't I can't but what ended
up happening was I [ __ ] kissed all
damn night
yeah and ain't nobody make no [ __ ]
complaints I yeah she and in fact they
enjoyed it yeah the [ __ ] and yeah
and it was like the the energy was great
they wanted more and more and so in my
head I'm like man this is [ __ ] crazy
wait was that was that was the kissing
issue that you had with Jess was that
something that was since day one or is
that later on when things started going
sour between you two I didn't even know
that I sucked at it but I believe that
it was after things went sour so it's it
to me anything that was said in the past
or whatever it's forgiven and I'm not
holding on to it it's just I'm using it
as an example for sure right but then I
do believe it's probably something that
was said out of spite but it still [ __ ]
with my head at the time of course cause
like when things are bad like you know
and you guys are not like coexisting in
a very happy place a lot of that stuff
that you know you said to where she said
to you was just out of venge being
vengeful ya know and you don't even know
that you're saying it sometimes right
and it's just and I don't think we
really think about the consequences and
the repercussions of what we say during
those heated emotional times and it
tends to carry with some money right
like for example being told that you
know you're not that great of a kisser
and it starts to become true that there
is said to you over and over and yeah
and I don't even and I don't even have
the confidence to kiss another person
because I already told myself like oh
she's probably not gonna want it yeah
yeah but she wanted more and she's like
mourn [ __ ] man it was crazy because
yeah it's like dancing right so it's
likes with some dance partners you could
[ __ ] move in its natural and other
dance partners it just doesn't work yeah
so it's an energy thing right so I
started to recognize this like okay
there's people out there that just
[ __ ] watch you for who you are and
there's other people that you have to
work for it yeah and I know this is
cliche and people say that but now I
know what that means
mmm like it just [ __ ] works and it
makes sense and it's so natural and then
you're appreciated and all these things
and I'm like oh man this is what people
were talking about do you think
you going out to Europe and kind of
dating again kind of just recharge their
batteries in terms of like the dating
scene because if seems like you know
before dating and you know you finding
these things out it was like a lot of
the stuff that kind of mentally [ __ ]
you up in terms of your self-esteem as a
man in terms of being like feeling that
you're attractive or wanted do you think
like this your trip kind of like help
flip that like 180 for you I kind of put
you back hell yeah dude
kissing it holding a woman and having
them want you yeah like there is no
other feeling of validation than that
yeah like like [ __ ] dude and I didn't
even have to work hard for it I was just
myself mm-hmm that's the thing is like
when people say oh just be yourself
that's what that means yeah it just
happened naturally and I'm like God dang
dude like yeah and I think I think I'm
also a little bit different too because
because my self-esteem was a certain way
I wasn't thirsty I was just hanging out
yeah without expecting anything and I
think I don't know to me it's it's it's
kind of weird right cuz I know there's a
lot of beautiful women that slide in the
DM z-- comment they wanna whatever like
they want meat right what and I and I
recognize that but when it's also in the
flesh because you know at the end of the
day we're around a lot of good-looking
women but it's all work mm-hmm
you know like there's a lot of hot
models and actors or whatever but it's
all work right and it's been over six
years or so that I've been dating and in
that feeling so what happens to a man's
psychology if you're not a cheater
is you have one giant a syndrome hmm so
what and like you get so used to being
loyal that even after your loyal filler
you're treating kind of but more so you
forget that there's other women for
options yeah so
I got so used to being in a relationship
that when I am around beautiful women or
whatever my mind's already not thinking
of them as a potential mate oh it's just
bodies it's just people yeah right and
then it worked to your advantage though
right because it allowed for you to be
yourself and just have a conversation
without any ulterior motives which
allows people to be comfortable and I
think like that you know when people
think that phrase of you know just be
yourself I mean there's certain caveats
right like just be yourself doesn't mean
you go full-throttle and act all crazy
around somebody that you would around
somebody you've been around for years
right just be yourself means that that
you have a lot of likeable qualities
about yourself and just relax yeah you
know and I'm not there trying to bang
every girl that I see yeah which was me
my early twenties or whatever those can
smell that [ __ ] from a mile away yeah so
I'm just talking getting to know them
hanging out and it's working it's just a
matter of I think there's a lot of guys
who they also do this thing where they
they are themselves but they can't see
signs and that's the hard part right
it's like like like I know guys who who
can talk to a lot of women and but they
kind of think about it after the fact
that like well how come I couldn't
really like take them home with me or
like get to get the date is because well
you could you didn't jump on the science
right yeah after you you you were
comfortable with them conversation was
great you kind of just were like all
right
they friend-zoned themselves exactly so
you got it let's see me I don't I don't
friends on myself as soon as I see an
opening I go what is this here she'll
comes out there were times when I was
just like how is this happening to me
right now I am the luckiest [ __ ]
on the earth like she's touching me I
even had to make the move she just
invited herself to me that's looking
crazy and I'm like wow why am i Ben is
am I being blessed because the last
several years have been so painful yeah
with the rejections in the fighting and
whatever and now it's just nothing but
love like nothing but invite invitations
man
that's crazy I did I would have never
thought that you would have been messed
up like that from that just because I
didn't either until you didn't know huh
dude I almost honestly meant I had this
one passionate [ __ ] experience it was
so intense that I almost [ __ ] cry
like a little [ __ ] it was intense yeah
and it's not because I never experienced
it before it's because I didn't realize
how much I needed it and how much I
missed it and how much it was like
[ __ ] breathing like everyone should
have this and just to feel wanted and
like completely in tune and connected
that is something that I was just like
[ __ ] this is what I've been missing out
on that's the interesting thing too
because I think sometimes when you're in
a really bad relationship or people who
are in a long-term bad relationship they
convinced himself that the shitty
situation that they're in is how
relationships are supposed to be yeah
and it's not it's not no that's normal
thing so you kind of missed the passion
you miss all these great moments that
you have with somebody and yeah when you
when you're with somebody for a longer
time obviously it's not the same fire
that you had when you first started but
it's a different type of passion it's
not the same it's different but I think
for you in your case it was more like
you probably thought Oh long-term
relationships are without even really
grows cold that's what I thought
mm-hmm cuz I you know I always attribute
it to not having good role models right
like whether its family or whether it's
in my own house or or you know people
that I know it's not yeah it's just it's
just everyone's working through their
[ __ ] and no one has the answers no one
and no one's I don't know what it's
supposed to look like yeah so I think
the only person that really pointed it
out to me was Steve and Nikki yeah
they were like that's not how it's
to be man yeah and uh and I was like
really and he's like yeah he's like it's
uh it should feel it shouldn't be work
it should just feel right yeah I'm like
okay didn't know what that meant but
right about the time when we were
breaking up Steve was like I'm really
happy for you like for what's coming and
I'm like what are you talking about he
goes once you start dating again once
you start getting into that place you're
gonna realize what you missed out on and
he was exactly right yeah and I think
because the feelings were so fresh for
him right before like when he started
dating Nikki again because he when he
got out of the Toxic he was in a bad
relationship before Nikki
he's like oh I saw exactly what you're
going through it's like that's what I
was going through and I'm like oh [ __ ]
dude cuz I didn't really look forward to
dating honestly cuz I'm just thinking
about the drama again I'm like why would
I want to get with another person and go
through the drama again why like why
would I want to do that and I'm like oh
man that's not the point though that
[ __ ] happens like a year later the
honeymoon phase is [ __ ] awesome
yeah the honeymoon phase awesome like
this podcast is brought to you by future
baby well my friends
how important is Fitness to you because
fitness is very important to me now you
guys already know I do have a personal
trainer but when I'm on the go right
what I'm traveling a lot when I'm doing
stand-up shows when I'm doing send foods
I'm doing all these stuff I can't bring
my personal trainer with me well guess
what that's where I have future it is
awesome it keeps me accountable it has a
trainer that I can have at my fingertips
electronically my friends with my Apple
watch that keeps me accountable and sets
up a workout for me that I can do while
I'm on the road and a lot of people too
if they get a little they feel a little
weird about having a personal trainer
and going somewhere else this is kind of
the thing for you and I really
appreciate it it helped me is it's
helped me keep accountable and it's
helped me keep my weight off since I've
lost about
like 70 pounds so for those of you who
don't know what future is let me let me
let me give you a little breakdown
future pairs you up with one of their
world-class trainers and coaches and
creates a personalized workout plan
tailored specifically to your schedule
your routine your goals and your
progress your coach checks in with you
daily to keep you on track
accountability sending text making
adjustments to your routine and
following your progress logged on your
Apple watch super easy super seamless if
you don't have an Apple watch it's not a
problem when you sign up the training
future they send you everything you need
including a freakin Apple watch so don't
overpay for a trainer get the workouts
you need to meet all your fitness goals
and take your trainer with you wherever
you go with future it's amazing so sign
up for future today at Tri futurecom
slash brain and you get 50% off your
first month that's tri futurecom slash
brain for 50% off your first month
that's tri futurecom slash brain and you
know for people out there who are in the
long-term relationships where you're
afraid that the passion might die I put
it like this I've never really thought
that my passion would die right and it
hasn't it's just my passion has changed
something into something completely
different like before it was his
animalistic thing and this is just a
stage of this is just a stages of
relationships or attractiveness right so
before something becomes love you you
have this animal interaction right where
it's just [ __ ] kissing making out all
the [ __ ] time well later on when you
find a really great solid relationship
and you find sustenance from this person
this thing morphs into something else
immortan they're like how I would
describe it for myself and this isn't
true for everybody else but it's like my
passion now is like I don't have to have
sex every day we don't need this but
just having that person's presence
around me is is it's something that I
just can't replace yeah it becomes a
necessity which is so interesting right
it doesn't mean that I'm not a whole
person without her like I'm still a 100%
me and I still find joy and doing stuff
without her but having this person that
kind of like makes makes everything a
bonus is the part that that passion
turns into yeah you become this unit and
this team
that yeah without hurt you'll still be
functioning I'll still she'll be
functioning I will be I'm a hundred
percent Who I am
but then she becomes a hundred and fifty
percent and that's that's that's what
passion turns into passion turns into
kind of like this it's hard to explain
man like it's it goes passion then it
becomes like a family like I don't know
this is weird the comfort the Gov you
melt like every day kind of melds
together right and so you don't you
don't look for your affection and
validation through having having
constant sex and making out all the time
now now it's just like I just need this
person to be there and support me and
that's all the love that I need right
obviously you still [ __ ] have sex but
you're not doing it like how you used to
before where it was something that you
desperately needed him or else you
wouldn't feel validated you know which
is kind of good man like I like this
whole thing like this Europe trip was
actually something that was it was
healing man yeah it's like you were just
like so thankful like a minnetonka did
you dipped yourself right there dude I
like dating now dude are you are you
like open market now huh I feel like I'm
healed I think now it's more about
creating quality connections like bi you
just kind of getting your [ __ ] a foot
back in the water right now man yeah I
don't know if I'm I don't know I'm not
even gonna make a rule cuz I'll say like
I don't know if I'm ready for like a
relationship and I get into one do you
like having fun right now yeah it's it's
there's nothing to it it's just meeting
people and creating connections like
whether we [ __ ] or not I think that's
super important because now I'm having a
different relationship with just people
in general the dynamic and the man it's
it's different it's beyond just having
fun mm-hmm now it's about energy and
vibing and it's like a whole different
experience that's really what dating is
though man like and I said this before
too in a passion of videos like people
will be surprised that when it comes to
dating is like before you find your one
that you're gonna be with if if you know
like a monogamous relationship is for
you dating is not so much
learning about another person is more
about learning about yourself and what
you needed yeah and it's it's it's like
I always say this too when you first
date and you're and you're dating not in
a serious relationship it
I believe anyways it's okay for you to
be selfish because this is a moment for
you to figure out what you need from
this person and what that and that
person too should figure out what they
need from you and it's it's it's what I
found out too it's like oh I'm learning
things about myself
the first girlfriend that I was ever
with I thought that her type was the
girl that I meet it turns out after I
dated somebody like that it was like oh
I actually found out you're not my type
at all and then when I was for a
different role you're not my type when
we started we started picking apart
these people that were dating and then
we actually find pieces and puzzles from
them that actually kind of helped
complete you and your identity of what
you need out of a partner yeah I think
you're back on that journey right now
yeah and I'm loving every step of it
yeah cuz I think for us and from an
outside perspective too and you know you
you we I think the cool thing about you
and Jess is that you tried really hard
to make it work all the time yeah and
even for us from an outside perspective
we can't tell you that it's not working
because you have to realize it yourself
yeah right so it was like you know for
Jess she yeah I mean she goes hikes and
she's active and stuff like that but it
has to be on her time you know so when
she doesn't have a migraine when she is
feeling it when only when she wants to
yeah so it was hard for you because
you're up and go type of person you're
like yo the move strikes you down you
down I think that's why we always work
yeah right because even though I'm with
a very spontaneous yeah and you're free
exactly yeah I'm with Mary album Arielle
has her own life and she doesn't need to
be with me whenever I go do my stuff
with my guy friends so if you hit me up
I have a free schedule like yo go to the
beach I'm like let's [ __ ] do it yeah
you know and I'll go until I have a kid
and I'm [ __ ]
you know there's a different story you
know yeah but that'll be less years from
hopefully I have a kid at the same time
or whatever yeah I got a few years of me
left so don't worry about that that we
got a few years yeah but yeah you're
completely right man I think it's an
energy thing right it's about matching
energies matching like person like I
mean it's just at the end of the day
your energies did it match what it was
yeah and they're what I feel like
they're
was a time that it did but it went to
different directions yeah so yeah I mean
in the beginning to passion kind of
cover covers up a lot of our personal
wants right because we just want to be
the most fun and the most exciting for
the person that were attracted to yeah
so I think a lot in the beginning we do
tend to lie a lot right not not because
we're both trying to look for a prove or
just enjoy each other too so we set
aside our selfishness right but I think
that's where looking back I feel like
that's how people kind of [ __ ] it up
because you stopped dating you know how
they say don't stop dating mmm and I'm
like oh man that's why you don't want to
get too comfortable because when you get
too comfortable you get too selfish and
you're not selfless enough it's kind of
weird how people treat each other so
[ __ ] good in the very beginning and
treat each other so [ __ ] bad later on
yeah we we had this conversation to it
Barry
oh I had this conversation station too
with material where we have this
tendency to sometimes treat our friends
better than we treat each other yeah
right and there's there's a couple of
factors to that that I think we realized
where it was like one it's because the
no matter how close I am to a friend the
person that you're with in a
relationship their words will always
hurt more than anybody else's yeah their
opinion about what we do our art our
careers our jobs our life choices if
they say something negative about it if
if a friend says something negative is
like yeah but if you say it hurts a lot
more yeah so sometimes we kind of come
ready when when we receive this opinion
or critique or this negativity to come
back and snap back at each other yeah
right and so with if it was in the
dating phase that probably wouldn't
happen because at that moment we're
still kind of dating and still we're
developing our friendship still so we're
allowed to manage those emotions better
and it's it's it's hard sometimes mm-hmm
because we do we do tend to like treat
other people better than some of our the
people that we should treat the best
yeah yeah that's that's true I mean yeah
I think there's just different phases
right and it keeps things interesting
yeah but I mean you're in that passion
like that dating phase to which I
remember was [ __ ] fun men there
there's a point in my life to like if we
were I was talking about this on the big
mood podcast where she both kind of gas
me up a little bit she goes the guy
who's Dated so I haven't I haven't been
with a lot of women like straight up
like I've slept with if I if I tell you
how many women I've slept with it's
they're still all in these two hands oh
right so isn't it's not much so I mean
for most people is I mean other people
might think it's a lot but I'm making it
in comparison to a lot of the guys that
I know they slept with way more women
than my numbers way lower so for me
hookers don't count hookers oh god then
it's in the millions down here but like
for me it was like I didn't get into a
lot of serious relationships a lot and I
didn't hook up with a lot of women but I
did date a lot and the reason why it was
because like I said there was a point
where I realized in my life that I
didn't know what I wanted after my first
relationship failed because I convinced
myself that this is the type of woman
that I meet and then what I found out
was that I only I should have just
called it off earlier when I knew it was
wrong even as a 18 year old when I was
with it from 18 to 19 I knew that we
weren't right for each other but I kept
on trying to take this [ __ ] square
block and the fitting into this circle
hole no matter what you know what I mean
and I kept on trying to make it work but
what I started doing was dating a lot
number one was because I wanted to be a
stand-up comic so I wanted a lot of life
experience which was great couldn't work
for my stand-up comedy also number two
was to figure out what I really need out
of somebody and dating was really
[ __ ] fun because I didn't put a lot
of pressure on it Wow there was no
pressure you're so emotionally
intelligent
I just got fun most of my life it was
does this dick fit inside your purse I
yeah
I don't think you know I think I was
kind of lucky because you know like
obviously when I was younger I had a
huge sex drive but then I also got
annoyed really easy you know so that
always prevented me from just really
kind of like wanting to [ __ ] somebody
like if they annoyed me it bothered me
there's also probably because I had a
temper but if they have just quality
about them that I couldn't get past if
we couldn't connect emotionally I didn't
want to have sex with you really yeah so
like a lot of the girls that I dated and
I always cut it short right before we
would even
try to get intimate because I know that
I wouldn't do well damn that's crazy I
think I've always had a short temper but
I've always found girls adorable yeah I
don't know I like I've always been like
that it's weird because in high school I
couldn't get a girl to look at me at all
you know yeah and then when I started
becoming more comfortable with myself
and just not giving a [ __ ] and then just
being able to talk to women
I mean mind you it was a lot of work
because man I look like hot trash but
then I had to you know move past that
and go through like 4,000 rejections to
get one girl to say yes and when it
would happen
the end goal wasn't to really [ __ ] them
it was more like man I just want to get
to know this person see if we could
connect and then me and then yeah we'll
[ __ ] I mean I'm that's later in life for
me obviously when I matured but for the
longest time I think I was blinded by my
horniness it even even till now though I
it's really hard for me to get what's
the word like like annoyed I guess of
women in that way yeah where I'm just
like oh like I'm so turned off yeah
usually if they smell or physically look
like that's that's what turns me off
there is some traits now or I'm just
like wow this person is crazy
it's all or if they're really depressing
or negative that's that's what it would
feel like to be though I know that
feeling yeah yeah yeah that's what it
would feel like and also too it's like I
think it's because I also didn't know
how to just hook up with somebody yeah
because the way I would start something
is that we would connect we would like
kind of connect are you looking for
someone that's like this is a potential
marriage material maybe I think I was I
think that's just how I develop
relationship you're the first one so
even if I was just doing it casually it
would end up like that where it was just
we would open up have deep conversations
and it would turn out to be something
more than just hooking up am cuz I'm
always like you can be a hookup you can
be marriage you can be a friend whatever
but can I have fun with you that's yeah
yeah yeah yeah like just not even sexual
but it's just like can I have fun with
this person and then I move to the next
stage I mean like but it's not
sacred I want you know [ __ ] a few
girls be like will you talk about we
hooked that like I there are people that
I've hooked up with before right where
it was just a hooker but mind you if
that happened I was probably either
really drunk and I was going through a
dry spell so it's like you have to
really get me to that point where I'm
deciding off guard was like [ __ ] we're
not even emotionally connecting but I
just really want to find what that has
happened before but it wasn't it didn't
happen often you know for me too when I
I think my threshold for annoyance
breaks down over the years that I'm
around them yeah cuz at first I'm just
like you are so [ __ ] cute you are so
adorable
yeah and it's like to me it's almost
like a like like a cute kid messing up
mmm and then later it starts getting
annoying yeah well you got what you
wanted and then it's like or she got
what she wanted to and it works out that
way yeah and by the way just to just to
encapsulate what I'm saying right now
because you guys all know what I used to
look like before and everything else
this is like me making like 10,000
swings and then one hits me like is that
like when I walked up to women it just
worked it's like I had it no it never is
that way for any of us had to make him
laugh I had a joke around we I had to
show what I had to offer to and then if
that didn't work I you know hit on
another girl hit on another girl and
then maybe something somebody finally
said yes I just wasn't scared of
rejection and I got rejected all the
[ __ ] time it was just you know who's
like I think right now is probably the
best dating I'm ever having like the
choices the quality like trying to make
it sound like it's a [ __ ] meat market
but exquisite exquisite it's great a
great no I think I think the thing is so
here's the thing right like I think
people in general are smarter now than
before so I have a I have access to
beautiful multicultural intelligent
women when before it was more local dumb
either sgv [ __ ] you [ __ ] a Bee Gees
you know what I mean there's nothing
wrong with that but I was a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
- yeah so my world was small yeah and my
axis was small
now it's like damn dude I have access to
the world and on top of that it's just a
whole different yeah I mean it's just
the experience is different like I'm out
here because I have money and because I
have a little bit of like access to
resources right like I'm I can date in
Europe dude like that's a little bit
different well yeah I mean even like
tinder to is awesome like you can go
internationally with that [ __ ] and then
you could date out there like the the
options now to meet somebody is endless
it's almost I got a buddy who [ __ ]
looks for tinder dates all over the
world because he travels a lot and then
he sets up his dates that way that's
perfect and he's like yeah I'm gonna be
in Japan I'm gonna be in Europe hey you
want to hang out okay cool I'll see you
in [ __ ] a week or whatever and then
he's there and it's like man what an
international man of mystery it's weird
because like you know it's kind of cool
it's like these these skills of like
just being able to talk to people not
just women um kind of it still applies
now right like if I if I strike up a
conversation with a woman it's still fun
it's very entertaining but now it just
feels different now it's like there's
literally no other motive for me to talk
to you other than the fact that I just
want to talk to you
yeah and like there's nothing there I
think that's still the same for me too
like I think a lot has changed because
now I can get it whenever I want like I
literally can so it doesn't I don't I'm
not thirsty anymore
yeah I'm and then I'm just honestly I
have way more fun making money right now
and building businesses and doing that
then I do [ __ ] yeah so I think I'm at
that point where I'm like oh [ __ ] man
I've changed that's why the I think the
quality of your interactions as an adult
especially when it comes to the dating
scene has improved now it has cuz now
you're just not looking for a hole to
put your dick in and now it's like this
person is worth my time the fun the
energy that I'm getting from this person
and if I [ __ ] I want a quality
passionate connection which is way
better lovemaking or I mean I don't know
if it's making love if it's really fast
but it's still intense compared to an
encounter that you just kind of
I mean it's both our hookups right yeah
but one is like just a quick physical
one and then the other one it might be
quick but it's a passionate physical I
don't know how to explain it I think I
mean this kind of sounds bad but this
can goes this is obviously what I say
this is a poor men but obviously women
obviously have this too it's like it's
like when you hook up with somebody that
you respect it's like you know so much
more about them right other than just
like we saw each other and then we just
started making it on we [ __ ] I don't
know if it's respect cuz I still respect
both yeah I don't know I guess I owe
something I don't know if that's the
right oh yeah yeah it's like you know
even though it's like an inch deep of
knowledge of them it kind of gives you
sustenance that you're [ __ ] right
that allows that passion to have yeah
cuz before if you don't really if you're
just basing it off somebody's face
that's I mean what-what passion is there
behind that it's more like well you're
just there and I'm I'm just here for you
and you're just here for me we're just
gonna [ __ ] ya when you when you connect
with somebody I think the way that you
have what you're having conversations
with these people you're having dinner
you're going out even though it's an
inch deep and it's only surface level is
still something and allows that allows
you to have like a passion yeah it's
kind of like what happens throughout the
night right yeah and then what you talk
about and then even the hook-up is
intense like it's like oh [ __ ] this is
like some honeymoon [ __ ] mm-hmm it's not
quick like porn [ __ ] yeah I will not
explain it like man I never kissed so
much and did all the [ __ ] passionate
stuff it's just weird
maybe that's normal for other people but
for me [ __ ] man I barely kissed for me
it was just like I'm like you ingest
didn't kiss a lot when you guys were
started going out no no I mean it's no
offense to her it was just everybody
even previous girlfriends I was like I
rather have a [ __ ] [ __ ] why are
you kissing me like oh he's up here
phille I was a complete barbarian bro
like it was just like I lived the [ __ ]
[ __ ] make money life he was just I
don't care
mm-hmm it's like okay you know
we're gonna go eat some food and then
afterwards [ __ ] imma eat your [ __ ]
you're gonna suck my dick like that yeah
you know like it wasn't even passion and
emotional it was just cold and I think
there was a lot of issues I had and
thankfully Jess brought you know she she
unlocked a lot of [ __ ] she helped me out
a lot so if it wasn't for that I
wouldn't be where I am today exploring
and experiencing these new I guess parts
of Who I am that I never really got to
enjoy because maybe I blocked that part
of emotionally connecting with people
and now that I can experience it and I
can live in it and it's it's so intense
and I'm just like this is dope I want
more yeah yeah well look at you men just
grown and blossoming do [ __ ] your did
wonders for you man I gotta go back
panda stand man it's not just a dating
but the people in general like the women
and the men in the hanging out with
everybody just it's a whole different
world like literally I feel like you
could experience a lot of that stuff
here too probably it's just you know
like I said it just allows you to have a
fresh start somewhere else where it's
like it's cuz there's a completely new
environment because there's a lot of LA
is where you grew up
yeah you know la is something that and
we've met quality people here yeah I
know a la mean we're locals in most
quality people or the locals because a
lot of the experiences I think that
you're having over there it's the
experience that I have when I first
moved here yeah you know I mean when I
used to always go out in k-town DTLA get
drinks hang out [ __ ] party and all of
this [ __ ] like that's that stuff that it
because it was it was a new environment
for me yeah yeah I mean so you it's kind
of hard for you to get that here this is
your hometown
this is I've been here all my life
you're right yeah I'm just yeah you're
right it's the environment man mm-hmm
that probably plus I mean in general I
think the dating is just different there
too
oh yeah people are different yeah are
people I mean if there's any Australian
listeners
that I heard you guys are just a lot
more open and friendly and just more
open to new experiences out that you
guys aren't so like you're not wound up
yeah that's the thing is I didn't feel
that from a lot of people out there
which is the great feeling like we could
just sit down and the conversations are
deeper that's what I noticed so la it's
really true what they say that's what I
realize oh [ __ ] man they we are shallow
surface
stupid [ __ ] people cuz you know like
for us to have conversations like this
like deep mud like it's difficult to
find that that's why all of our friends
are entrepreneurs and entertainers you
try to have this conversation with a lot
of other people they don't like to get
too deep they don't like you know or
they'll just be sitting there with their
mouths open like damn you talk deep bro
and it's like well I want something back
from you yeah I feel like a lot of
people here are specifically in LA
because they're either in entertainment
or they have this perception of what
they should be if they're living in LA
that they're very closed off and they're
not willing to be open that's the thing
openness is the thing out there and you
can sit there talk about everything
people talk about politics and they
don't get their butt hurt yeah and I'm
just like what very intellectual
community like I mean that's a crazy
thing for me because it's so volatile
here and you mention anything about
politics which is so annoying like I cuz
I'm not somebody who's well-versed and
this is what I found out too and this is
a conversation that I actually just had
recently with a friend and I had to
check this [ __ ] you know who the
[ __ ] you are you're listening to this
we're good friends by the way but he
didn't even know how angry he was
getting as he was talking to me because
I didn't know something that he was
passionate about right so like for
example he's he's hyper yang gay right
I like what he hangs about I just don't
know enough yeah so for him I guess he
wasn't a part of the democratic debate
right and for me I don't know what the
general importance is of the democratic
debate and what it does for these
candidates right and he goes and he was
telling me like he's not a part of the
damn it
it's so racist bubbeleh blah and I was
like well why is it racist and wise this
is important because well how come you
don't [ __ ] know this like you're an
Asian American and I'm like hold on a
second bro back the [ __ ] up yeah I mean
you're getting riled up because it has
to do with politics you're getting all
up in your [ __ ] your dick is
inverting into your [ __ ] stomach
you're getting so mad right now so I
looked at them I was like when somebody
doesn't know something don't raise your
voice yeah right I'm just trying to have
a conversation with you yeah I'll say
but every time it comes to politics you
get [ __ ] mad and you talk to people
like they're dumb because they don't
know [ __ ] about stuff that you're
passionate yeah [ __ ] relax right if
you can't explain it to me in a normal
tone I'm not gonna listen and I'm just
gonna say [ __ ] that's gonna piss you off
all day I love Trump yeah I'll start
saying [ __ ] like that yeah you know I
mean but that's when it comes to
politics people get so heated that is or
just other topics right yeah and so now
I know why people think Americans are a
bunch of buffoons
cuz I'm like [ __ ] dude out there you can
have conversations mmm
it's just I mean sure you might have
your extremists and all but like the
general thing was you can talk about a
lot of [ __ ] and a lot of people there
are educated so even the party girls
even the what you might consider to be
like you know like the average person
right like everyone talks everyone it's
the culture there you drink coffee you
hang out you talk for [ __ ] hours
mmm-hmm you go to [ __ ] bars you drink
there's substance in the conversation
whereas like man it's hard to find that
here you know and I'm like [ __ ] dude no
wonder and that's what I really
appreciate it hands-down out of all of
my experiences in Europe I think just
the connecting with people and sitting
down having conversations I think that's
what I really liked yeah yeah that was
really cool that conversation part is
super bright and obviously I think the
and it made me want to [ __ ] harder I
think that's what it was that's why I
was so passionate man keep talking as
well I think is getting hard man please
isn't that weird what what would get you
going now as an adult when you mature
poor's when you were younger because I
feel like if I just saw anything I get a
boner
it's literally anything yeah if a girl
bent over I mean I still get a boner
today yeah but then like yeah it's like
that would still give you a boner today
but but it's it's your right though like
now it's like say something that tickles
my brain so I could tickle my other
brain yeah yeah but right now [ __ ]
get this going right here motivate me I
wonder if it's because like we're also
looking for I mean oh it's just a dating
situation but there's still the thing in
the back of our mind is like we're
looking for a future mate so it's like
something that you could spend your life
with even though you know that person is
not going to be it it's nice to know
that that person has that quality I I
think for me I'm afraid of stupid people
because they could get me in trouble
mmm so it's like all right you're cute
but I know I've okay so I've been around
enough to I where I know girls that are
or just people in general that are kind
of stupid they'll get you in trouble so
one way or another and then you start
even if it's a hookup or whatever
they might do stuff in the that's that's
really [ __ ] dumb mmm that can rub off
on you you know I mean like they'll do
some moves that are that could get you
in trouble there's they're high risk I
think that's what I'm thinking about is
you're a [ __ ] dumbass you're
high-risk most dumb asses are high risk
yeah because they'll drag you down with
them most losers are high risk because
they'll drag you down with them they'll
make mistakes in life they'll do
something shady maybe sometimes
impulsively unintentionally some people
they're just [ __ ] morons and you know
this right and they'll make mistakes
they'll get in trouble they might ask
you along with it or whatever might
happen they are gonna drag you along
with it and I'm just like do I want to
get involved with this person because I
know for a fact that repeatedly people
that are dumb people that are loser
people that are like their repeat
[ __ ] ups they'll somehow catch you
because for example maybe not you
directly but they might date a [ __ ]
dumbass that comes around and wants to
be violent with you
they might date a dumbass who's like oh
you know this guy he has money showing
me show me where he lives
sure I'll show you oh yeah my phone
Condon there diagnosed he was gonna Rob
you yeah yeah you know like so there's a
lot of instances where dumbasses can get
you in big trouble so that's what I'm
always thinking and I'm like that ass is
hot but is it worth it you're stupid
yeah I mean if you I mean obvious if
you're hooking up you don't really I
think that deep he's gotta hook up and
move on but it it crosses my mind even
if it's a hookup yeah it kind of turns
you off yeah and I'm like I don't know
about that man she's trouble she's
trouble with his dumb ass yep well yeah
cuz I mean [ __ ] not just cuz she's dumb
but like man like she really doesn't
watch her own back
I guess scared of emotionally unstable
people yes that's another dumb ass trait
yeah
no mass no mado masked man like they
like emotionally unstable freak people
freak me out because they only ride on
highs right so it's like if everything
is going their way and things are great
they're the best person to be around
right they treat you well the moments
great but the moment there's friction
like you dist don't turn on y'all turn
on you ya instantly and they become very
vindictive and I've seen that happen a
lot personally to me to where it's just
like oh like you only [ __ ] with me if I
agree with you but if I don't agree with
you I'm your worst enemy you hurt their
ego and they want to destroy you I hate
that [ __ ] yeah it's like well you
[ __ ] found out that you're crazy and
I'm ten times crazier I'm gonna make
your life way worse and I think over the
years we experienced that right so it's
like you're hot but do I really want to
deal with that isn't that crazy though
like how like when you're older you can
kind of pick up on this right when
you're younger you're like I never had
anyone as hot as you please touch me
yeah like before I met Muriel it was you
know it was dating around like messing
around it's just kind
like things are going well and then I
see this a little crazy in them and I'm
like red flag I'm out so a girl that
those girl that I was dating before
Mariel and it was a friend of mine and
when I first of all my gut instinct told
me that she and I should not be together
right but we dated either way it's
because she approached me very nice we
were like chat over the phone whatever
whatnot DM each other all the time
and this girl was like hey you know
we're good friends we get along really
well won't we just try dating and I was
like I'm not really too sure about that
right but what I really appreciated was
that she went out of her way to ask me
out right which was really dope we
started dating and she was visiting
visiting she came over whatever things
were great she did this one small thing
that there was a huge red flag to me she
goes we had a disagreement on something
and I know buddy was angry I was like I
don't think that's right right she goes
well what the [ __ ] it was like what you
think that everything I say is dumb or
what and I looked at I was like yeah you
need to get out like that I was like you
got to get out and she goes why she was
why I was like in the funny thing and
I'm saying this laughing because the way
she said why was I she didn't know what
the [ __ ] she just said to me yeah I mean
like she didn't just escalate the whole
situation and she goes why I was trying
not to laugh but I look it I was like
you have an issue with people
disagreeing with you and I'm not
somebody who's an agreeable person I
will never just agree with you just to
agree with you if and I was like we've
only been dating about a week now and
you already snapped at me over something
and that was nothing I'll say this is
something this and I could tell that's
been taken above what you do is it
person so let's just keep it as friends
this isn't gonna go but right now I'm
upset because you yelled at me
mm-hmm and over nothing it was something
this small and you saw somebody who
disagree with you and it's it is a habit
of yours that can already tell and I
kind of saw it with you it cuz we're
friends mm-hmm that you do and I was
like in a relationship now is ten times
more amplified so right now you got it
bounced because you pissed me off so she
bounced and then we kind of we just
called it quits I think that's what I
watch out with my age now because it's
like no matter how hot a grow is hmm do
you want to deal with that baggage do
you
wanted because everyone has baggage
mm-hmm so it's like you gotta weigh out
the pros and cons and that's where I'm
just like man I'm not even dating but I
am dating yeah and it just things fall
into place because my that's where I
wasn't looking forward like to make this
go first full circle it's like that's
why I wasn't looking forward to dating
cuz I'm thinking about that you know I
want to deal with their baggage do I
want it whatever right but when you
emotionally connect with someone none of
that [ __ ] matters you will you will deal
with it no that's what I didn't realize
hmm you're like who cares that's the
logic thinking you know there's gonna be
problems always there's that whatever do
you want to deal with it probably not
but that's coming from a mind that's not
being emotionally fulfilled when you're
emotionally fulfilled you're like yeah
I'll deal with their [ __ ] because
you know why she makes me feel complete
yeah look I love her yeah so you know
because everybody has baggage I have
baggage you have baggage it's just I
mean obviously it depends on what that
baggage is some of us aren't really
strong enough to deal with that stuff
yeah like I I know for a fact that um
yeah if I don't really love this girl
and I don't see her having a willingness
to change and I don't see it's too early
to deal with the [ __ ] that's why I
think it's kind of like we're supposed
to be in honeymoon and you're already
[ __ ] yelling at me like we're an old
married couple [ __ ] that [ __ ] like that
type of baggage is not something that
I'm willing to deal we neither when it's
that early yeah like yo that type of
stuff should happen later it's been one
week like we barely just started [ __ ]
you know I mean come on what the [ __ ]
yeah like yo chill the [ __ ] out and then
for her and like I said we've already
been friends so I've seen this side of
her before but just not to this extreme
and it's like y'all when you're with
somebody it's amplified it's like yeah
you're you're crazy that's gonna be
crazier yeah and you know that's her
holding back yeah and we're still like
you know we're we're friends lightweight
you know I mean like we're not like
close close we're still friends and you
know she's she's she's I think she's
married now she was engaged but I've
seen her interact with her fiance does
the same [ __ ] she like thank God snaps
at him all the time she didn't learn her
lesson no because that's just who she is
and that guy just [ __ ] takes it you
know that's perfect that's love
right yeah I don't really know if you're
ever listening to this you know and I've
told her to it's like yo ease up cuz
we're friends you know I'm like ease up
off him a little bit right just you know
how I get you know I mean but I'm safe
well it's not my problem but if I if I
see it and we're friends I'm like backup
like it'll be like some [ __ ] like we
went to we went to go out to eat and
this was years ago
and this is when she was with this guy
and I think they're married now I
haven't really followed up but like
we'll go out to eat and he she would be
like some [ __ ] like I don't know sweetie
can you pass me the water right and then
he'll give it to her but he'll fill his
fill of a cup like halfway and she goes
are you [ __ ] kidding me like how am I
supposed to drink this just like know
what a princess yeah you know I mean I'm
like yo chill the [ __ ] out I mean are
you serious yeah and like like that's
just an example I'm not saying that's
exactly what happened like on some [ __ ]
like yeah and then you know as friends
where we're at this dinner I'm like
trying to defuse the situation I'm like
oh here she goes being a little [ __ ]
this again it mean she starts joking
around but I know for a fact but that's
how she talks to him all the time
because I experienced a little bit of
that oh my god
I am I would immediately run away as I
ran away I ran away in a week damn I was
like nope it's not working out adios see
that's the part of dating that scares me
yeah well you don't got to worry about
that this was somebody that was a friend
and turned I should have said no in the
first place but it was so nice that she
has so your gut was right yeah I think
that's the thing it's all about the gut
man the gut knows it's a good thing and
the guts been had been saying go this
way go that way and I'm like alright
I'll follow and I think you're a smart
enough person and you have so much life
experience now especially after your
last relationship I think you have a
really good gut feeling about things now
and even if it does fill it's not gonna
be catastrophic now yeah right so you
have a good like relationship dating
like barometer you know where you're
going yeah and I'm able to navigate
conversations better now mm-hm and
create a better dynamic between the
people that I'm talking to and hanging
out with so that's the biggest
difference between being single and not
because like for me I had this ability
before Muriel if I'm talking to somebody
whether it's a guy or girl to actually
give a [ __ ] about what they're saying
it's the conversation now I know that
when I am at home
maril comes home she wants to talk to me
for a couple of hours so that's where my
brain energy has to go some when a girl
talks it's like I don't give a [ __ ]
about what you're saying dude I could
really [ __ ] care less I don't care
dude it's like well let me tell you
about my day who the [ __ ] cares I gotta
go home and I gotta listen to Muriel
talk it's so like for you I don't care
dude
they just just go about your way it's
not that simple but I'm saying it's like
I could do it like very surface but if
it's like me having to listen to them
like a therapist it's not gonna happen
oh I don't even do that for friends
anymore yeah I think it's too much like
we're done here we're done I got to do
this I don't absorb [ __ ] no more
it's hard but now what I understand what
to do is like flip it really quick mmm
so like I don't let people live in their
misery anymore no and I don't sit there
and I don't convince them so the thing
is like I let people get then and do
what what they got to do but I don't try
to fix their problems I let them do
their [ __ ] but I try to get them to feel
like I I feel like if I have strong
energy I can help them snap out of it
mmm so it's not that I'm convincing them
or anything but really like making them
feel good mmm and I think that's been my
new thing of like okay how do you dive
how do you change this so we don't stay
in this thought and feeling for too long
yeah yeah and so like that's one thing I
noticed I started doing too while we're
like hanging out date going on dates or
whatever is if any topic starts to get
heavy
I don't avoid it but I also stay away I
understand now
because I love arguing debating or
whatever depending on the person you
gotta know that relationship and this is
what guys [ __ ] up a lot especially nerdy
guys and intellectual guys if you love
to [ __ ] argue if you love to debate
if you love to talk about things that
are really [ __ ] deep make sure you
don't argue and debate with the person
that you're dating with that [ __ ]
happens all the time and I'm like why
did I do that
you don't compete with them because it
creates this dynamic that's more of a
battle than a lover you want to protect
them you want to feel you want to make
them feel feminine around you you want
to make them feel like not attacked and
when you're doing that mentally when
you're intellectually bullying them or
whatever then it then it creates a
different dynamic between the two of you
if she's always do that huh a lot of
dweebs do that yeah also for women too
if she's always relying on you as an
emotional tampon she gets to spill all
of her [ __ ] right that's fine but what
ends up happening is she sees you as her
Gossip Girl now not a man you're her
homegirl that's where you get
friend-zoned yeah so sure you could talk
about issues and whatever but make sure
that that's not all that's going on well
that's what a lot of guys confusing
about that that whole like friendzone
thing right it's it's how you establish
yourself within that relationship that
allows it to flourish into something
else if you were just there right and
you just made it seem like you guys were
only going to be friends and like joe
said you were there just to absorb their
[ __ ] that's as far as they were
going to see you because you didn't
offer something else and this is where
guys who are [ __ ] dweebs I call you
dweebs because you think that that small
amount of affection means that that
person liked you mm-hmm
and that wasn't it no it wasn't
established you didn't try anything
they're like you're a great therapist
thank you exactly that's the
relationship so you created that dynamic
which is the therapist client you know
and is it is it the woman's fault for
that no absolutely not unless you
offered your ears because she went in
knowing what she wanted from you yeah
you went in not offering something that
you wanted from her yeah and then it
didn't go anywhere so whose fault is
that
that's your fault dweeb you know yeah
and you're also the dweeb to be angry at
women for it like fate like nice guys
finish last you're don't say that [ __ ] I
mean nice guys fell I was nice and I
finished first yeah
I think if you ask any of our female
friends or the women that we've been
with we were nice guys so what the [ __ ]
does that mean it's just that we weren't
the creep that decides to try to fake
being friends and try to get in their
pants after yeah you're the [ __ ]
creep
yeah and that's what I like about dating
I think is the is that the the whole
like experience of it and I'm like man
that's why they say women are way more
mature than men in a lot of ways because
they saw that [ __ ] from a mile away at
an early age mm-hmm or guys don't
[ __ ] see it yeah
they're it's it's it's in your face but
it's not you're not reading it yeah and
I'm like [ __ ] dude this is what I've
been missing out on so now I think the
whole it's just dating is just not about
hey do you match the criteria do I match
the criteria it's so [ __ ] robotic
right dating is like let's go [ __ ]
have fun and can we match energies and
vibes and stories and what can we kind
of supply for each other
well that's as far as Davey should go
right and that's just beginning stages
then open don't worry about all the
other [ __ ] right now if you find out
later on that there's something wrong as
I call it like your pillars like I have
pillars in my life that can't change
right it's like number one it's like
family friends and then my religiously
these are things that are important to
me right if I'm just trying to date
right why bring this up in the first
[ __ ] date why yeah like it's like
yeah these are important to you but if
you're just trying to get just have fun
first mm-hmm let's see what happens
after yeah
and it's been fun it's been crazy fun
man it's been it's like man I don't even
know what to do with it amen it's it's
just getting started baby well how long
have we been doing there we've been an
hour and 13 minutes ended you know
what's funny is after my breakup video
that we did where I'm talking about how
my heartbreak when I was in here yeah
yeah I was a [ __ ] cupful else cry
like a little like I got a ton of
[ __ ] messages from of course you did
good the like I could mend your heart oh
my god
like that was me at high school yeah
that was me when I was [ __ ] 15 is
[ __ ] guys where were you in high school
oh yeah dude I'm telling you man there's
there's always some women out there for
you did people be surprised man just
gotta be open and vulnerable and that
was the [ __ ] that when we were younger
it's the stuff that we would hide from
women because we didn't want them to
[ __ ] think we're a bunch of [ __ ]
but guess what girls like some when
you're open and vulnerable yeah which is
awesome well guys hope you enjoy that
podcast yeah man
Joe is blossoming into a new dating man
so ladies hit him up in his DM send him
messages dude now is the time because
once he becomes locked down he's a
faithful [ __ ] so good luck true
even if it's toxic yeah the genius brain
podcast every Thursday is Sundays you
can see us on iTunes Spotify any type of
audio platform out that we're there for
you guys so we'll catch you guys next
time
and ladies peace to the low